another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation no leasing out  the living room  scp-002 is a room constructed from flesh  hair bones and other substances that  make up the human body it is in the most  literal sense possible a living room it  has also been responsible for the  disappearance of several members of  personnel and should not under any  circumstances be leased or rented out to  civilians or foundation staff this  includes listing the place on craigslist  posting ads in local newspapers or  renting it out on airbnb for hapless  tourists even if staying in scp-002  wouldn't result in one's untimely death  dr bright doesn't even have a real  estate license